c'est un bras de fer qui semble sans fin
et il fait partie de ceux qui ne lâchent
rien d'ailleurs lorsqu'il n'est pas avec
ses collègues grévistes
aymeric le cheminot reste connecté à ce
mouvement qui lui a déjà coûté beaucoup
je suis un 23 jours de grève
23 jours de grève pour l'instant -
serment de toute façon déjà avec mon
épouse
dès l'instant que je lui ai dit toute
façon je rentre en grève je ne sais pas
pour combien de temps très sincèrement
on pensait pas en est encore quand on a
commencé le 5 décembre on pensait pas qu
au mois de janvier 2020 on y sera encore
et bien on va se serrer les coudes un
toute façon c'est comme ça on est
solidaire et puis ma femme on j'ai la
chance qu'elle travaille aussi donc
et puis même à fabre on va faire avec il
y a quelques jours nous avions déjà
croisé ce contrôleur sncf lors d'une
manifestation militants à la cgt à la
france insoumise
ce père de famille de 44 ans a le cuir
plutôt solide
il a surtout l'habitude de livrer
bataille
c'est le combat en 2013 déjà qui m'a
mise c'était le combat contre le as
l'équipement agent seul c'est à dire la
suppression sur certaines lignes des
contrôleurs à bord des trains donc ça
veut dire que le copain conducteur lui
il est tout seul à bord il est tout seul
à bord les gens c'est débrouillez vous
l'intérieur mais lui qui a déjà perdu
presqu'un mois de salaire comment
voit-il ce qui a la sncf n'ont pas
rejoint le mouvement
les copains qui font pas grève après moi
je vais avoir joué de sincère j'ai eu
beaucoup de mal 1
à part la personne qui m'avait remarqué
qu'il dit je suis pour cette réforme
c'est à dire qu'il a le droit
la droite de dire moi je suis pour cette
réforme donc j'ai fait zéro jour de
grève le copain qui dit bah moi j'ai
fait deux jours de grève
ça me paraît un peu compliquée est-ce
qu'on va se parler ce que savait dur la
reprise c'est toujours dur après
une un conflit quel que soit le conflit
c'est toujours dur la reprise est
toujours du toujours très tendue en
attendant demain comme d'autres
cheminots à dole aymeric pauvret sera de
nouveau en grève